♪♪
Tyler:
Here. We. Go.
♪♪
Throughout Season 1, Shelia is
becoming this aerobics
personality.
Are you ready to change?
Women:
Yes!
She gets approached by a
commercial agent who promises
her exciting things ahead.
Rose Byrne:
Her husband, Danny loses the
local election that he’s running for.
You see these two broken people
and you wonder, well, how are
they in a relationship together?
I don’t remember asking you for
your input.
Rose Byrne:
She struggled with all
relationships, but particularly with women.
I have a really hard time
opening up to other women.
The dynamics between women can
sometimes be complex
and Greta really values her
relationship with Sheila.
Bunny is very suspicious to
Sheila.
Della Saba:
Bunny envies Sheila.
Her business did not take off
and now she and Tyler are paying
the consequences.
I get a bad feeling.
I get a rad feeling too.
Sheila’s in the midst of her
addiction.
Rose Byrne:
She's found strength through the
aerobics
Rose Byrne:
and then she starts this very
strange thing with John Breem.
What’s next, Sheila?
Rose Byrne:
Season 2 is the beginning of
Sheila breaking free and doing it her own way.
She's desperately trying to get
her business started.
Bunny and Tyler finally have the
dirt on Sheila.
Della Saba:
We've been leading up to getting
our revenge.
She took everything.
Then let’s take it back.
Greta and Sheila's relationship
has grown a lot in between the
seasons.
Hello Gorgeous.
The Rubin’s are definitely in a
different place now.
I hate you!
(Scoff)
Rose Byrne:
There’s a brand new character
this season, Vinnie Green
Rose Byrne:
who's this strange competitor
slash mentor.
We could get you on a road to a
healthy, happy new you.
She figures out a way to win,
which doesn't always mean it's
the right way to do it.
(Laughs)
Sheila:
5... 4... 3... 2... 1...
Here we go!